wir sind zurück hier eben den beratungen
zum haushalt 2022 der letzte einzel plan
für heute zumindest am zweiten tag steht
jetzt auf der tagesordnung vor wenigen
minuten hat die dazugehörige
ministerinnen gesprochen es geht um den
einzelplan 23 für wirtschaftliche
zusammenarbeit und
entwicklung da gab es einen aufwuchs
bereinigt 12 35 milliarden und die
ministerin svenja schulze wie gesagt
hatte vor wenigen minuten gesprochen wir
wollen ihnen das von vorne zeigen und
starten so in den einzelplan
der 24 februar markiert eine zäsur in
der deutschen sicherheitspolitik das
haben die heutigen debatten hier noch
mal sehr sehr verdeutlicht ich sage
ausdrücklich auch ich als
entwicklungsministerin unterstütze das
sondervermögen für die bundeswehr viele
haben gehofft auch ich dass wir
schrittweise in eine weltordnung kommen
die konflikte ohne waffen lösen kann
aber putins brutaler angriffskrieg hat
diese hoffnung zerstört
militärische fähigkeiten sind notwendig
aber sie alleine führen uns nicht in
eine friedliche welt mehr noch sie
dürfen nicht das erste mittel der wahl
sein weder in unserem handeln noch in
unseren köpfen
neben den täglich sich überschlagenden
ruf nach schweren waffen müssen wir
gemeinsam auch wieder unsere stimme für
nichtmilitärische wege zur
konfliktbewältigung und vor allen dingen
für konfliktprävention erheben und dafür
braucht es eine starke
entwicklungszusammenarbeit
zusammenarbeit die ungleichheit die
hohner die armut als treiber und
verpflichten bekämpft die bildung die
gesundheit die zivilgesellschaftliche
kräfte und demokratieentwicklung stärkt
und das ist es was eine friedliche welt
von morgen braucht und deshalb setzt die
bundesregierung auf einen dreiklang aus
diplomatie entwicklungs und
verteidigungspolitik die
entwicklungspolitik mit ihrem
langfristigen ansatz ihrer partner
orientierung und ihrer starken lokalen
verankerung ist ein kernstück dieser
strategie
gleichzeitig kann die
entwicklungszusammenarbeit gerade durch
diese vernetzung schnell reagieren und
negative folgen von kriegen abfedern
nahrungsmittelknappheit und steigende
energiepreise dürfen unsere
partnerländer und das internationale
system nicht weiter destabilisieren und
dieser ansatz zahlt sich aus laut
berechnung der weltbank reduziert jeder
euro der in resilienz investiert wird
die kosten künftiger humanitärer krisen
um mindestens vier euro liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen ich möchte die
gelegenheit hier nutzen danke zu sagen
danke für die unterstützung für die
entwicklungspolitik in den beratungen
zum haushalt 2022 13 35 milliarden euro
für entwicklungspolitik das ist das
ergebnis unserer gemeinsamen arbeit hier
und darauf werden wir weiter aufbauen
müssen durch den völkerrechtswidrigen
angriff russlands auf die ukraine sehen
wir alle die notwendigkeit von
entwicklungszusammenarbeit hier in
europa und ich bin ja letzte woche in
die ukraine gereist um den
entwicklungspolitischen park vor ort zu
betonen und noch mal über unsere zivile
unterstützung zu sprechen mein
ministerium hat ende februar mit einem
sofortprogramm auf den russischen
angriffskrieg gegen die ukraine reagiert
und mit ihrer unterstützung hier liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen konnten wir
unser sofortprogramm verstetigen und so
werden wir auch in zukunft einen beitrag
leisten können das
entwicklungsministerium knüpft damit an
die seit 1993 bestehende zusammenarbeit
mit der ukraine an und sie baut auf der
partnerschaft mit
zivilgesellschaftlichen organisationen
den kirchlichen zentralstellen
politischen stiftungen sowie mit
internationalen organisationen auf ein
kernstück ist die zusammenarbeit mit
ukrainischen kommunen sie funktioniert
und sie ist ein beleg dafür dass
entwicklungspolitik mittel und
langfristig wirkt denn die kommunen
setzen gerade jetzt maßgeblich das
entwicklungspolitische sofortprogramm
schnell und sehr wirksam und ich kann
ihnen versichern dass unsere
unterstützung vor ort wirklich dringend
benötigt wird ich war am freitag in
borodjanka das ist ganz in der nähe von
kiew dauert es ein
trauriges ein furchtbares beispiel für
die zerstörung durch die russischen
soldaten und jetzt wenige wochen nach
dem abzug der russischen truppen es
nicht nur die notversorgung
wiederhergestellt sondern beruht lanka
nimmt zusätzlich noch binnenflüchtlinge
auf und ich bin wirklich beeindruckt von
der kraft der menschen dem leid etwas
entgegenzusetzen
[Applaus]
vielen dank frau ministerin dass die
zwischenfrage zu lassen und keine
selbstverständlichkeit in dem haus ich
will sie konkret fragen sie hatten es
gerade selber angesprochen es gibt eine
zusammenarbeit in dem fall hatten sie
die ukraine genannt seit 1993
was mich immer wieder bei der
entwicklungszusammenarbeit bei der
deutschen beschäftigt ist dass man viele
jahrzehnte mit staaten zusammenarbeitet
aber wir eigentlich den grundsatz hilfe
zur selbsthilfe verfolgen was glauben
sie wielange ist es eigentlich richtig
mit staaten zusammenzuarbeiten bevor man
eben an den punkt kommt dass man
dauerhaft
staatliche aufgaben übernimmt das kann
ja nicht ziel deutsche
entwicklungszusammenarbeit sein was will
diese bundesregierung in zukunft in
diesem zusammenhang anders machen wollen
sie das mal zeitlich begrenzen es kann
nicht sein dass wir jahrzehnte
staatliche aufgaben übernehmen und dann
starten sie hatten gerade ukraine
genannt wenn wir den korruptions index
anschauen immer noch bei ländern wie
angola und co angesiedelt sind vielen
dank
herr abgeordneter vielen dank für die
frage in der zusammenarbeit mit der
ukraine haben wir es geschafft kommunale
strukturen aufzubauen wir haben es
geschafft von über 11.000 gemeinden
jetzt zu rund 1700 gemeinden zu kommen
die dann eben vom staat auch zusätzliche
aufgaben bekommen haben und diese
struktur zahlt sich jetzt gerade auch in
so einer krisensituation sind das jetzt
funktionierende einheiten sind das
kommunale verwaltungen die schnell
reagieren können und es zeigt dass
solche langfristigen
entwicklungszusammenarbeit sehr erfolg
reich ist wir müssen jeweils gucken was
ist in den partnerländern notwendig wie
ist die situation vor ort man kann nicht
vorhersagen na klar in fünf jahren würde
es einen krieg geben und deswegen machen
wir jetzt wie es und jenes das lässt
sich nicht so einfach planen und
deswegen ist der unmittelbare kontakt
und dieses partnerschaftliche auf
augenhöhe und eben nicht sagen wir
wissen alles besser das ist die
grundlage unserer entwicklungspolitik
und das werden wir auch weiter
fortsetzen
tipp vielleicht auch die gelegenheit
nochmal zu sagen dass wir eben seit
vielen jahren mit solchen gemeinden wie
borodjanka in der ukraine zusammen
arbeiten und ich war sehr froh dass ich
jetzt in kiel versichern konnte unseren
kolleginnen und kollegen dort dass wir
ein starker partner war bleiben werden
wir werden diese unterstützung weiter
ausbauen wir werden uns am wiederaufbau
einer freien und demokratischen ukraine
beteiligen und unser kanzler olaf scholz
hat hier ist ja heute hier in der
debatte noch einmal eindeutig gesagt wir
werden die ukrainerinnen und ukrainer so
lange unterstützen wie es nötig ist die
folgen des krieges sind darüber hinaus
aber eben auch weltweit zu spüren es
droht die schwerste hungersnot seit dem
zweiten weltkrieg die g7
entwicklungsministerin und minister
haben mitte mai deshalb gemeinsam mit
der weltbank das bündnis für globale
ernährungssicherheit gestartet das
bündnis dass ich vorangetrieben habe
wird bestehende strukturen zur
bekämpfung von hunger unter einem dach
zusammenfassen und kurz und
langfristiges engagement international
koordinieren unsere zusage von 430
millionen euro für ernährungssicherheit
war ein ganz wichtiges signal an unsere
partner und mein dank geht an sie dass
sie diese zusage noch während der
vorläufigen haushaltsführung möglich
haben aber
das habe ich immer gesagt der große
angriffskrieg wird auch folgen haben
über die unmittelbaren folgen in der
ukraine in den entwicklungsländern es
zieht sich durch die heutige debatte es
erfordert eine neue
sicherheitspolitik mit einer gut
ausgerüsteten bundeswehr einer klugen
diplomatie sowie einer starken
entwicklungspolitik die im künftigen
krisen vorbeugen die schwerpunkte meiner
arbeit bleiben der kampf gegen hunger
und armut die justin sischen also der
fähre wandel hin zu einer klimaneutralen
welt der einsatz gegen cupid 19 und für
resilient ihre gesundheitssysteme und
eine feministische entwicklungspolitik
als zentraler beitrag für gerechtigkeit
und krisenprävention und
belege sind kollegen ich erinnere mich
noch gut an die erste lesung unter allen
demokratischen fraktionen waren wir uns
einig dass der zweite regierungsentwurf
für den bmz haushalt den globalen
herausforderungen nicht gerecht wird
jetzt stehen für dieses jahr 13 35
milliarden euro für die
entwicklungspolitik zur verfügung das
ist in etwa das niveau der ausgaben mit
denen das bmz das jahr 2021
abgeschlossen hat und diese
haushaltsansatz erlaubt es
entwicklungsländer bei der bewältigung
der cupid 19 pandemie weiter zu
unterstützen und von den
koalitionsfraktionen wurden wichtige
umschichtungen vorgenommen etwa zur
stärkung einer feministischen
entwicklungspolitik und in der
bereinigungssitzung wurden noch
zusätzliche mittel bereit gestellt dass
es so gekommen ist das war keine
selbstverständlichkeit und ich danke
ihnen hier ausdrücklich für die
unterstützung
ich sage aber auch ganz deutlich
sorgen bereitet mir und damit komme ich
auch zum ende der ausblick auf die
kommenden jahre für 2023 sind in der
finanzplanung bisher nur 10,7 milliarden
euro vorgesehen angesichts anhaltender
herausforderung bildet dies bereits
jetzt die bestehenden realitäten nicht
mehr ob die folge des hoffentlich bald
beendeten russischen krieges werden uns
lange fordern in der ukraine in den
östlichen partnerländern und den vielen
entwicklungsländern afghanistan syrien
und der nahe osten der sahel und das
horn von afrika bleiben hotspots von
konflikten und hunger und die verstärkte
zusammenarbeit mit vielen ländern asiens
afrikas und lateinamerikas ist
erforderlich um den globalen
herausforderungen von forward
forderungen vor allem den klimawandel
und dem verlust an biologischer vielfalt
wirklich gemeinsam begegnen zu können
deutschland muss auch in zukunft einen
angemessenen beitrag zur agenda 2030
leisten können auch damit wir die
militärischen fähigkeiten die wir jetzt
schaffen wirklich nicht nutzen müssen
hier setzt sich auch weiterhin auf ihre
unterstützung für die
entwicklungszusammenarbeit und sage
nochmal ganz herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
svenja schulze die
entwicklungsministerin hier zu ihrem
einzelplan das haben wir ihnen gleich
zeitversetzt gezeigt ja sie war als
zweites mitglied der bundesregierung in
kiew und hatte kam nicht mit leeren
händen sozusagen die ukraine hat zivile
hilfe zugesagt bekommen 185 millionen
euro soforthilfe maßnahmen
beispielsweise um wohnungen wieder
aufzubauen oder auch stromleitungen
insgesamt svenja schulze zumindest mit
dem nachschlag den der
haushaltsausschuss er noch einmal
bewilligt hat ihrem ressort durchaus
zufrieden die rechnungen 12,35
milliarden stehen im einzelplan und eine
milliarde noch etwas versteckt im
einzelplan 60 für die allgemeine
finanzverwaltung
aber für die nächsten jahre da und sagt
ihm müssen hier aus hält er muss das
parlament vielleicht noch mal drauf
schauen so wir sind mitten in der
aussprache zum einzelplan ist für die
fdp claudia raffelhüschen
investition mit sicherheit eine für
beide seiten sehr zufriedenstellende
rendite erwarten können wenn
man in diesem zusammenhang von rendite
sprechen darf es ist gut dass wir auch
in der bereinigung diese linie
fortgesetzt haben und beispielsweise
nochmals fünf millionen in den gp ii
fand der vereinten nation stecken mit
dieser global partnership for education
unterstützen wir nämlich die
verletzlichsten kinder in den ärmsten
ländern zu den mädchen leider fast
automatisch gehören der zugang zu guter
bildung ist für diese mädchen essentiell
um sich ein in jeder hinsicht
selbstbestimmtes leben aufzubauen
ökonomisch physisch und auch mental in
dieselbe richtung zielen die
zusätzlichen 20 millionen euro für den
stern center war auch hier verfolgen wir
den nahe liegenden weg auf qualität und
bewährte multilaterale akteure zu setzen
ein ganz wichtiger punkt wenn wir
sicherstellen wollen dass unsere gelder
nicht unter dem motto gut gemeint aber
nicht gut gemacht versichert ich bin
fest davon überzeugt dass nur eine
entwicklungszusammenarbeit sinn und
zukunft hat die genau da ansetzt bei
bildung und qualitativ hochwertige
betreuung und gesundheitsversorgung für
kinder
und natürlich beim import von mädchen es
war nicht sonderlich
schwer vorauszusehen was die lage aber
umso bitterer macht der ukraine krieg
und die sanktionen gegen russland
bedeuten für viele länder vor allem in
afrika das hungersnöte schon jetzt kaum
noch abzuwenden sind oder das bereits
vorhandene nochmals verschärft wurden es
ist daher gut dass deutschland mit dem
geplanten bündnis für globale
ernährungssicherheit aktiv voran geht
und dabei sicherlich auch auf die
unterstützung des parlaments hoffen und
banker wichtig
wichtig ist aber auch dass wir diese
schreckliche situation nutzen um
bisherige schwachstellen und
versäumnisse entwicklungszusammenarbeit
kritisch zu beleuchten
sprich es ist auf dauer nicht zu führen
es ist auf dauer nicht zielführend auf
akute hungersnöte mit den immer gleichen
importen der immer gleichen produkte aus
ganz wenigen ländern zu reagieren wie
anfällig das system weizen aus russland
und der ukraine ist wird uns gerade
brutal vor augen geführt stattdessen
müssen wir sehr viel stärker an der
residenz der betroffenen staaten
arbeiten ökonomisch politisch und vor
allem in sachen ernährungssicherheit und
noch etwas
noch etwas ist uns wichtig dass wir
neben dem blick auf die akuten krisen
pandemie folgen hier ukraine krieg dort
nicht die vielen anderen globalen
herausforderungen aus dem blick
verlieren das wäre besonders bitter weil
wir hier ja durchaus schon einiges
erreicht haben jetzt das eine zu tun und
dafür das andere zu lassen das wäre
wirklich fatal daher war es auch ein so
wichtiges signal dass deutschland
zusätzlich 165 millionen euro in den
globalen fonds zur bekämpfung von aids
tuberkulose
und malaria steckt denn gerade in afrika
denn gerade in afrika ist für 100
tatsächlich ein wesentlich geringeres
gesundheitsproblem als befürchtet
dagegen seien aids tuberkulose malaria
weiterhin massive bedrohungen die durch
die über große aufmerksamkeit auf corona
fast vergessen wurden was sie de facto
noch gefährlicher macht zum schluss
möchte ich noch einmal auf das
zurückkommen was sich schon in der
ersten lesung gesagt habe und in meinen
reden immer wieder holen die
schuldenbremse ist keine unzumutbarkeit
sie ist zumindest in krisenzeiten auch
kein selbstzweck sie ist aber ganz
einfach das beste instrument für
haushalterische nachhaltigkeit das wir
haben und nun im leh die schuldenbremse
schnell wieder einhalten kann
deutschland sich langfristig leisten in
absoluten zahlen der zweitgrößte und
relativ zur bevölkerung in vielen
bereichen sogar der größte geber in der
internationalen zusammenarbeit der
entwicklung zu bleiben und das ist unser
ziel hindern
dann sagen wir claudia falschen gefühl
die fdp-fraktion sie ist eine der
berichterstatterin für diesen einzelplan
jetzt für den sprecher für
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit und
entwicklung der union volkmar klein
was sie denn meine
damen und
die beiträge
haben schon so ein bisschen deutlich
gemacht dass in diesem jahr der
einzelplan 23 oder ich will mal besser
sagen die finanzierung der arbeit des
ministeriums für wirtschaftliche
zusammenarbeit und entwicklung so
unübersichtlich sind wie in der
vergangenheit noch nie
andrangs
vorübergehend 600 millionen euro im
zweiten regierungsentwurf im einzelplan
60 schon mal geparkt um über
planmäßiger ausgaben zu finanzieren
784 millionen euro für el also die
internationale impfkampagne aber neben
dem einzelplan 23 und eine milliarde
aus dem ergänzungs haushalt für
kriegsfolgen bewältigung weiterhin im
einzelplan 60 und nicht im einzelplan 23
globale mehrausgaben
wo nicht klar ist wer und wie
entscheidet wo die am ende ausgegeben
werden das ist schon ein stück problem
für die transparenz der finanzierung
unserer entwicklungsarbeit könnte man ja
sagen ja das ist ja nicht so schlimm
könnte ja sogar
besonders kreativ und deswegen gut sein
mag sein aber es wird natürlich
erhebliche gefahren weil der plattform
des einzelplan 23 ist eben nicht
entsprechend aufgewachsen nicht die
mittelfristige finanzplanung größte
problem für die zukunft aber immer als
benchmark die bisherigen ausgaben und
die sind eben sehr viel niedriger als
die gesamtsumme über die jetzt mehrfach
geredet worden ist
vielleicht hat sich die ministerin ein
bisschen über 16 lassen vom
finanzminister weil wenn ich dann sehe
wenn ich dann sehe
dass die vs die
verpflichtungsermächtigungen im
einzelplan 23 deutlich zurückgefahren
worden sind hinter das niveau von 2021
dann liebe frau kollegin hagedorn ist
das für mich ein sicheres indiz dafür
dass meine befürchtung sehr wohl
substantiiert ist
aber fangen wir mal vorne an positiv
ich möchte mich ganz ganz herzlich
bedanken
bei den ampel
koalitionsfraktionen dafür dass sie sich
unserer kritik am ursprünglichen entwurf
der bundesregierung angeschlossen haben
dass sie sehr massiv dass sie sehr
massiv auch eingefallen sind in die
kritik der opposition an das was die
regierung vorgelegt hat
opposition wird das kann man so ein
bisschen feststellen das betrifft die
gesamtsumme
weil sie haben ja gerade nochmal so die
kurve gekriegt
das betrifft aber auch einzelpunkte
einige wurden ja eben schon genannt also
zu klotzen die sonder initiative eine
welt ohne hunger angesichts der jetzigen
situation das war doch absurd den krisen
titel wollte die regierung von 936
millionen auf 550 millionen kürzen wäre
doch ein unding gewesen es ist gut dass
das alles vor
korrigiert worden ist dass die kürzungen
des kirchen titels
zurückgenommen worden sind deswegen ich
kann nur sagen
das ist sehr sehr gut dass sie in
letzter minute sich unserer kritik
angeschlossen haben und notwendige
kurskorrekturen vorgenommen haben das
loben wir
auch der anderen seite gibt es schon an
vielen stellen einen erheblichen dissenz
zwischen reden und handeln
jetzt ist eben noch mal gesagt worden
wie wichtig doch die förderung von
frauen ist hat das bmz auch eben in
einer pressemitteilung noch mal raus
gegeben und wenn ich dann aber sehr dass
genau da wo hauptsächlich frauen
gefördert werden weiterhin eine massive
kürzung da ist dann passt doch reden und
handeln nicht zusammen vielleicht weiß
die ministerin nicht vielleicht weist
die ministerin nicht dass mikrokredite
vor allen dingen frauen zugute kommen
herr kollege alonso eine zwischenfrage
aus der fraktion bündnis 90/die ja gerne
vielen dank herr kollege klein nachdem
sie jetzt zwei minuten für eine sehr
spannende ausführungen über
einzelplan systematiken genutzt haben
haben sie jetzt den weg zum inhalt
gefunden meine frage wäre an welchen
stellen sie also nochmal darstellen
können an welchen stellen jetzt ihrer
auffassung nach weniger für frauen
bezogene programm ausgehen wird
beispielsweise auch als in ihrem ersten
regierungsentwurf der schwarz-roten
vorgängerregierung wir haben ja nämlich
nicht nur eines zentralen aufwärts von
dem zweiten regierungsentwurf zu dem was
wir jetzt diese woche debattieren
sondern hier einen genauso großen
aufwands gegenüber dem von ihrer
regierung nach vorgelegten vorgängerin
vorgänger entwurf wir haben
beispielsweise deswegen gemeinsam mit
der regierung in einem guten miteinander
programme beispielsweise für die
finanzierung von frauen also das bff
dass sie vielleicht gerade im bereich
mikrokredite ansprechen wollten wieder
auf das niveau gebracht wo es war wir
haben die un women gestärkt übrigens
mehr als jemals in einer
vorgängerregierung dafür ausgegeben
wurde und wir haben auch beispielsweise
programme konnte frau dazwischen das
gerade ausgeführt in richtung
reproduktive rechte familienplanung und
so weiter erhöht gegenüber dem was ihre
vorgänger regierungen zustande gebracht
hat vielleicht ist es einfach noch mal
zahlen darstellen wo ich mich getäuscht
haben könnte
das ist schön dass sie die frau kollegin
raffelhüschen gerade nochmal erwähnt
haben die zurecht darauf hingewiesen hat
dass an vielen stellen frauen die
besseren unternehmerinnen sind und dass
es deswegen sehr sinnvoll ist genau dort
wirtschaftlich anzusetzen um
möglicherweise wissen sie nicht dass das
besonders wirksam über mikrokredite
möglich ist und möglicherweise wissen
sie auch nicht und möglicherweise weiß
dass auch die ministerin nicht dass der
titel im haushalt zusammenarbeit mit der
wirtschaft das ist der titel aus dem der
wesentliche für die wesentliche
finanzierung für die sparkassen stiftung
fließt und die finanzieren vor allen
dingen mikrokredite und wenn ich jetzt
sehe dass dieser titel von
267 millionen euro auf 194 millionen
gekürzt worden ist dann ist das für mich
das gegenteil von förderung von frauen
und ich will noch eine weitere zahl
hinzusetzen
ich hatte nämlich gestern gelegenheit
mit dem präsidenten der
sparkassenstiftung darüber zu reden weil
ich habe gesagt das sind 90 prozent die
frauen zugute kommen und heinrich haasis
hat mich korrigiert und hat gesagt in
vielen programmen der sparkassenstiftung
sind es 100 prozent das heißt sie kürzen
den titel der 100 prozent frauen zugute
kommt und das ist für mich das gegenteil
von der frage förderung von frauen und
insofern
ja das ist schon ein skandal sowie
kollegen am 100 prozentig recht deswegen
ist das etwas was sie sich sehr zu
herzen nehmen müssten und ganz generell
bin ich einfach sagen das ist auch ein
erfolgreiches otto aus nordrhein
westfalen reden reicht mich es geht
darum machen woran worauf es ankommt
genauer klassensieger schlusspunkt was
wir eben auch von der ampelkoalition
erwarten und wenn sie das machen dann
haben sie auch unsere produktion dabei
vielen dank
[Applaus]
nächste gegnerin ist die kollegen wird
die nagel ohren spd fraktion
liebe kolleginnen liebe kollegen
lieber volkmar klein
ihr habt hier als union am 23 märz in
unserer ersten lesung massiv in der tat
kritisiert wie niedrig mit 10,9
milliarden euro ein der etat war
und das übrigens haben wir auch getan
und das hat auch die ministerin gemacht
und wir haben jetzt 2,4 milliarden euro
mehr zur verfügung führt das haus
schneider gleich noch mehr drauf
eingehen und das ist ein großer erfolg
und das könnte zwar versuchen klein zu
halten aber es werde er nicht schaffen
und und ist es so dass wir uns nicht nur
vorgenommen hatten gemeinsam auch die
ministerin dass wir natürlich auch
eigene schwerpunkte setzen wollen das
heißt ja nicht dass wir mit der politik
des vorgängers georg müller aufräumen
aber klar ist auch dass wenn man neue
schwerpunkte setzen will und das soll
nicht alles nur und topcom was ja die
union massiv kritisieren würde werden
wir es getan hätten dann muss man eben
auch umschichten und da muss man
projekte auch evaluieren und eins ist
natürlich ganz klar da es eine
feministisch
entwicklungspolitik die unter heidemarie
heidemarie wieczorek zeul bis 2009
praktiziert und erfunden worden ist und
jetzt endlich in der gestalt von svenja
schulze wieder einen deutlichen
schwerpunkt erfährt in den zehn jahren
dazwischen
naja ein bisschen vor sich hin gedümpelt
hat und natürlich
hat es auch im haushalt von gerd müller
zum beispiel projekte zur mikro zins
finanzierung gegeben die finde ich super
die finden wir glaube ich alle super
diese bereits anerkannt aber trotzdem
ist es so dass der eigene zusätzliche
schwerpunkte setzen und claudia gipfel
ist ausführlich darauf eingegangen und
immer wenn man frauen stärkt wenn man
ihre rechtsposition stärkt wenn man sie
wirtschaftlich gestärkt dann stärkt man
auch die kinder dann stark man auch die
gesundheit der kinder dann investiert
man auch daran dass die frauen sich
darum kümmern dass es eine auskömmliche
zukunft für ihre kinder gibt und dann
wird man gleichzeitig fluchtursachen
entgegen dann befriedet man gleichzeitig
regionen und darum es eine solche
entwicklungs politik für und mit frauen
in erster linie auch eine politik die
den frieden stabilisierte privat
präventiv wirkt und dass es unser
hauptziel gemeinsam
und dazu gehört auch ein zweiter
schwerpunkt ja auch in dieser ampel
koalition natürlich viel stärker betont
als er bisher betont worden ist und
darauf sind wir gemeinsam stolz und das
ist der einsatz für klimaschutz und für
biodiversität besteht auch so in unserem
koalitionsvertrag und auch da haben wir
eine priorität gesetzt und auch das ist
natürlich ein punkt der klimawandel der
trifft die ärmsten immer im herz das ist
auch in unserem eigenen land so aber das
ist auch weltweit und es ist natürlich
so dass die folgen des klimawandels
vorrangig auch länder die sowieso schon
von dürren von starkregenereignissen von
sturm von überschwemmungen also von all
den dingen gekennzeichnet sind die
wirklich die lebensgrundlage der
menschen wecken nehmen die die menschen
zur flucht zwingen denen die armut und
die natürlich auch im kampf um land und
rohstoffe den krieg befeuern unter
nationen in gerade im südlichen teil
halbkugel und weil das so ist ist es gut
und es ist richtig dass wir einen
deutlichen schwerpunkt setzen und ich
glaube es ist eine gute fügung dass
unsere ministerin für wirtschaftliche
zusammenarbeit und entwicklung im nicht
nur den feministischen schwerpunkt setzt
sich im märz angekündigt hat sondern
dass sie in ihrer vorherigen verwendung
auch umweltministerin in dieser
regierung war und dass vor diesem
hintergrund ein völlig anderes
verständnis für den kampf für den
klimaschutz mitbringt als es andere
vorgänger vorher hatten und vor diesem
hintergrund glaube ich haben wir
gemeinsam einen guten wurf hingekriegt
1 möchte ich noch betonen weil ich hier
missverständnisse zu sein scheinen ich
bedanke mich bei den für die guten
beratungen nicht nur unsere haupt
berichterstatterin claudia fischer und
felix walleczek und unseren gemeinsamen
teams sondern auch der ministerin denn
einstimmig lieber carsten körper das ist
hier nicht alles von in ampelkoalition
von den haushältern also ich nehm lob
immer gerne entgegen aber nur für das
was wir gemacht haben wir haben aus
einem ergänzungs haushalt und aus einem
kleinen haushalt gehören zusammen gefügt
aber für den ergänzungs haushalt hat die
regierung gesagt und er als werden ja
schulze mit viel erfolg bei christian
für eine milliarde euro on top geworben
und die bekommen und es ist richtig und
darum haben wir jetzt eben noch die eine
milliarde im einzelplan 60 und dass es
hervorragend und wir haben eben auch
über elf überplanmäßige ausgaben mit
eingefügt in den haushalt die letzten
endes auch schon von unserem kanzler in
unserer verantwortung weltweit zu gesagt
und versprochen worden sind und die sind
hier auch mit eingeflossen das heißt das
geld das haben nicht alles wir besorgt
aber wir haben die schwerpunkte gesetzt
gemeinsam in enger absprache auch mit
unserem haus und ich glaube das ergebnis
kann sich sehen lassen und vor dem
hintergrund will ich nur noch einmal
sagen 2,4 milliarden euro mehr das ist
schon ein richtig guter schwerpunkt aber
weil auch darauf schon bezug genommen
worden ist in dieser debatte ja wir
haben in dieser woche schon sehr viel
über das militär und über das
militärische besprochen und das ist auch
richtig so und ich werde auch am freitag
aus voller überzeugung dem 100
milliarden euro vermögen zu stimmen und
wir haben ja gleich noch einer
haushaltsausschuss sitzung wo wir uns
damit noch intensiv beschäftigen werden
aber eins ist auch wahr
militärisches ist immer das letzte
mittel und jeder cent jeder euro den wir
in die prävention stecken und gehen wir
in die langfristige stabilisierung von
region und die menschen die dort leben
stecken ist ein viel kommt ein
vielfaches zurück und ist immer immer
die bessere lösung als das militärische
das ist der eine punkt den ich sagen
möchte und der andere punkt ist der dass
wir mit diesem etat die ministerin hat
ihre sorgen mit blick auf den einzelplan
23 also auf das jahr 20 23 angesprochen
diese sorge teilen wir fakt ist gebe
claudia wir haben einen
koalitionsvertrag da steht die
schuldenbremse tritt ja und das werde
ich auch nicht infrage stellen ich habe
sie selbst mit eingeführt wir sind
koalitionstreu
aber trotzdem hoffe ich auch auf die
unterstützung und das verständnis
unseres finanzministers dass in diesem
weltweiten krisen die wir haben auch ein
finanzministerium natürlich mithilft und
hoffentlich mithelfen wird und die
balance zwischen ausgaben im
militärischen bereich und in dem bereich
die präventiv werken weltweit
in diesem ressort aber auch im
auswärtigen amt herzustellen und das ist
unsere gemeinsame aufgabe ich bin
ziemlich sicher uns wird nicht
langweilig werden in den kommenden
wochen und monaten aber wir haben uns in
den ersten haushaltsberatungen absolut
wert eher sind ein gutes team mit den
freundlich miteinander um und für diese
arbeit die mir sehr viel freude gemacht
habe möchte ich mich ganz herzlich bei
meinen kolleginnen und kollegen bedanken
vielen dank sagt bettina hagedorn
stellvertretende vorsitzende des
haushaltsausschusses
und jetzt folgt ihr diesmal friedhof von
der afg
[Applaus]
herr präsident werte kolleginnen
kollegen lieber bürgerinnen und bürger
frau ministerin es geht um
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit und
entwicklung vielleicht besser bekannt
als gut finanzierte
entwicklungshilfe industrie um mir eins
klarzustellen die afg seht ihr kürzungen
vor weil die art und weise wie er geld
verpufft weder ziel noch
erfolgsorientiert ist es ist seit 65
jahren zahlt und da helfen neue
überschriften eben nicht denn wenn es ja
richtig und gut wäre müssten wir doch
eigentlich positive veränderungen sehen
und wahrnehmen aber wir tun es doch
nicht ich werde das jetzt hier aufzeigen
und als erstes kommen wir zu dem
selbstverständnis der regierenden dr
hoffmann der fdp sagte in einer seiner
letzten reden
entwicklungsgelder zu kürzen wäre so als
ob man einem bettler in der
fußgängerzone den hut fertigt und das
geld heraus liegt und genau dieses bild
was sie zeichnen wollen ist nicht das
bild was ich in afrika wahrnehmen und in
south africa überhaupt nicht gerecht
wird der arme der battle aber es zeigt
bewusst das dilemma der zu entwickeln
länder auf gewollte abhängigkeiten von
den spenden deswegen fordern wir seit
fünf jahren eine ehrliche selbst
entwicklungspolitik die der menschen
mental kulturell und sozial gerecht wird
mich stände klar aufzeigt und systemisch
denkt und handelt oder das
selbstverständnis der ministerin die bio
diverse klimagerechte feministische
entwicklungspolitik in die mitte des
ausblicks stellt das ist westlicher
ideologie export aber keine selbst
entwicklungs punkt und übrigens die
grünen die ja so ihre probleme mit
deutschland haben wollen indigene völker
in lateinamerika schützen ich hoffe mit
ihrer sprache mit ihrer kultur um mit
ihren werten und wenn das so ist dann
bitte liebe grüne beachten wir deutsche
sind auch indigene
da ihnen dieses selbstverständnis fehlt
ist ihre sicht eine falsche und damit
auch ihr lösungsansatz doch die ist
schon richtig sowie in unsere ministerin
zu karl may der in seinem leben heime in
amerika war jedoch nie ein indianer
gesehen hat aber das bild der europäer
über die indianer prägt
die amerikaner haben die indianer zwangs
kultiviert man nahm ihn die
lebensgrundlagen steckte sie in
westliche kleidung und gab ihn westliche
nahmen die geschichte ist uns bekannt
die indigene bevölkerung amerikas wurde
zum verlierer sozial kulturell
finanziell das indigene verschwand und
manche machten sie sogar sozial abhängig
man hat das selbstverständlich gut
gemeint und auch jetzt meint man es ja
wieder gut aber gut meinen heißt noch
lange nicht gut machen die zu
entwicklern länder sind arm wie nie
hunger sind hungernde und sind vergehen
wie nie niger mali burkina faso südsudan
zu dann viele andere länder sprechen
bände allein in äthiopien der einstigen
entwicklungs hoffnung am horn von afrika
sind in den letzten monaten tiger
konflikt 509 500.000 menschen getötet
worden aus afghanistan werden nach wie
vor tausende von rotz crafter nach
deutschland ausgeflogen alles an
entwicklungsleistungen die in den jahren
erbracht worden sind mit einem mal
erloschen ihre leuchttürme leuchten
nicht mehr das liegt eben auch daran
dass diese länder nicht selbst
verantwortlich und nicht reserviert
entwickelt worden sind weil ihre
entwicklungsschwerpunkte nichts aber
auch überhaupt nichts mit den
lebensrealitäten der menschen vor ort zu
tun hat denn das macht eben nicht satt
der tschad hat 70 prozent der stadt hat
70 nach ernteverluste und hungert warum
war ihre entwicklungspolitik frau
ministerin hätte ich zielführend in
mosambik wird mais angebaut und günstig
exportiert damit muss ein blick mail
weißmehl teuer geld importiert und warum
weil es in mosambik keine mühe gibt
warum ist das so 80 prozent der
baumwolle auf berlin verlässt benin ohne
weitere wertschöpfung in benin warum ist
das so frau ministerin der afrikanische
kontinent wird mit billigen eu situation
subventionierte lebensmittel
zugeschüttet so dass sich der anbau in
den eigenen ländern gar nicht lohnt
warum ist das so frau ministerin
afrika liefert uns günstige kaffeebohnen
damit man bei uns dann foren
filterkaffee kauft warum ist das so nach
20 jahren verlorenen jahr in afghanistan
und den katastrophalen abzug der
westlichen truppen bricht über nacht
eine hungerkatastrophe in afghanistan
aus warum ist das so weil ihre ansätze
und ihre ideologien folgend
20 jahre nach ihrer politik in
afghanistan führten dazu dass es mehr
kokain felder als je zuvor in diesem
land gibt und
afghanistan wird marktführer im
drogenmarkt wurde auch hier kann ich
sagen kokain kann man leider nicht essen
aber der bilder grüne
landwirtschaftsminister erste mir wohl
ein trend folgen wenn er fordert weniger
lebensmittel in deutschland anzubauen
und stattdessen hanf anzubauen nun die
politik der neuen regierung kann man
vermutlich auch momentan vertragen
fatale hier
dass die regierungsparteien einen antrag
abgelehnt haben sie haben letzte woche
ein antrag der cdu oder von zwei wochen
abgelehnt die nehme ich wollte dass wir
mehr weizen in zeitung keine krise hier
in deutschen landen bauen und damit
afrika unterstützen sie haben es
abgelehnt weil man ja das deutsche
klimaziel nicht gefährden will und auch
hier ist ihre sicht liebe grüne eine
falsche ja wir erleben einen klimawandel
es gibt einen klimawandel einen
natürlichen und dieser stößt nun auf
eine umweltkatastrophe die mensch
gemacht ist und zwar das zerstören der
weltweiten wald ressourcen und der
ungebremste bevölkerungswachstums runter
ungebremste ressourcen haben aber das
wollen sie alles nicht wahr haben da
steckt man sich lieber seine sdg 17
branche um und wird zum herr der ringe
beziehungsweise zu stein der weisen was
es braucht gerade für afrika mehr
wertschöpfung einen afrikanischen markt
um mehr industrie und in grundlastfähige
industrie ich komme gleich zur wende ja
das finde ich jetzt alles gut wissen was
das ist die agenda 62 63 der
afrikanischen union sind für schlau und
unterstützen wir den selbstbestimmten
weg selbstbestimmter völker und sams
verantwortung dankeschön
vielen dank
nicht zu reden ist die kollegin
thüringen bis 1907 sprecherin für
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit und
entwicklung der grünen
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident sehr
geehrte ministerin schulze liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
wenn ich morgens die zeitung aufschlage
dann befällt mich jeden tag aufs neue
angefügt von traurigkeit von angst von
traurigkeit wenn ich lebe die am
wochenende in der nigerianische stadt
port hat bei einer massenpanik
31 menschen ums leben kommen weil sie
angst haben dass sie keine der
lebensmittelspenden mehr bekommen angst
wenn ich jeden tag lesen wie die
klimakrise dazu führt dass immer mehr
menschen ihr zuhause verlieren
gut wenn ich weiß dass wir als gesamte
staatengemeinschaft dafür verantwortlich
sind diese krisen zu verhindern und
tagtäglich damit zu scheitern drohen wir
wissen dass nicht nur die klimakrise
oder die nahrungsmittelkrise sondern
auch alle anderen krisen zu mehr
vertreibungen gewalt hunger und armut
führen werden und wir wissen dass die
aktuellen krisen immer mehr werden mit
diesem wissen stehe ich ehrlich gesagt
gespalten vor diesem haushalt denn
innerhalb dessen das wurde heute schon
viel gesagt haben wir alles rausgeholt
was möglich war wir konnten die
kürzungen von über 1,7 milliarden euro
zurücknehmen und wir werden im jahr 20
22 13,3 milliarden euro in globale
gerechtigkeit investieren dass es
dringend notwendig und genau der
richtige schritt
und wir konnten auch grüne schwerpunkte
setzen das ist zum einen wie mein
kollege felix magath ja gerade schon
erwähnte die internationale kino
biodiversitätspolitik und die
feministische entwicklungszusammenarbeit
es ist aber auch die unterstützung der
zivilgesellschaft
denn gerade in schwierigen politischen
kontexten sind es zivilgesellschaftliche
organisationen die besonders wichtige
entwicklungspolitische arbeit machen wir
haben 15 millionen euro mehr für private
träger rausgeholt und 7 millionen bei
der stärkung von internationalen medien
denn freie und kritische medien sind
einem elementare grundlage für die
demokratie
und und das erfreut mich ehrlich gesagt
besonders wir haben klargemacht
steuergelder bekommen nur politische
stiftungen die mit ihrer arbeit die
demokratie stärken und sie nicht zu
ersetzen und das ist ein riesenerfolg
wir haben in diesem haushalt viel
rausgeholt und ich freue mich wirklich
darüber und ich danke den
haushälterinnen und der ministerin und
uns allen als ampel fraktionen für diese
wunderbare arbeit aber langfristig wird
es nicht reichen nur kürzungen einfach
zu vermeiden wir brauchen einen echten
aufwuchs dauerhaft mehr geld für die
entwicklungszusammenarbeit ist ehrlich
gesagt kein nice to have es ist ein must
have
wenn wir
wenn wir es ernst meinen mit der
globalen gerechtigkeit müssten die
mittel für entwicklungszusammenarbeit
und humanitäre hilfe im haushalt in den
kommenden jahren wie die
verteidigungsausgaben gleich ansteigen
und dass es nicht verhandelbar dass es
notwendig und wir reden hier in der
haushaltsdebatte über abstrakte zahlen
aber diese zahlen können über leben und
tod entscheiden sie entscheiden darüber
ob die krisen und pandemien noch zu mehr
ungerechtigkeiten und konflikten führen
zeitenwende bedeutet nicht nur mehr
militärische sicherheit zeitenwende
bedeutet gerechtigkeit nach vorne zu
stellen weil es eben auch in unserem
interesse ist dass alle menschen auf
diesem planeten in sicherheit leben
nicht nur in sicherheit vor krieg auch
in sicherheit vor hunger vorabend vor
krankheit und chancenlosigkeit lassen
sie uns gemeinsam für diese sicherheit
global sorgen
döring war das für die grünen ja der
einzelplan 23 ist wie viele einzelpläne
dieses bundeshaushaltes geprägt zum
einen von der bekämpfung der coop 19
pandemie hier im einzelplan
beispielsweise in entwicklungsländern
aber auch was die krisenbewältigung die
ernährungssicherheit im zusammenhang mit
dem krieg gegen die ukraine anbelangt
viel arbeit gemacht an dieser stelle
davon durchaus darauf hinweisen dass wir
erst einmal noch den haushaltsentwurf
der alten regierung zur vorlage hatten
aber mit diesem haushalt zeigen wir
jetzt dass die bundesregierung schnell
und entschieden auf die mehrbedarfe und
weltweiten krisen reagiert und ich
möchte mich da erst mal insbesondere bei
meiner kollegin claudia rachel typischen
aber auch bei den anderen kollegen aus
dem haushaltsausschuss kollegin hagedorn
kundige ballack und den kollegen aus dem
abi z ganz herzlich für die gute
zusammenarbeit weil dieser arbeit
bedanken
wir haben auch gerade zuletzt noch
einiges erreicht so haben wir die
selbstbestimmung menschenrechte von
frauen und mädchen durch erhöhte
beiträge an internationalen
organisationen wie dem bevölkerungsfonds
der vereinten nationen gestärkt das war
uns freien demokraten ein besonderes
anliegen nicht zuletzt weil wir wie auch
im koalitionsvertrag
vereinbart vereinbart die multilaterale
zusammenarbeit weiter stärken wollen das
gilt auch für die global financing
facility über die wir die gesundheit von
kindern und jugendlichen auch in diesem
jahr wieder mehr fördern durch die
erhöhung des titels multilaterale hilfen
zum weltweiten schutz der umwelt der
biodiversität und des klimas leiste
deutschland einen im internationalen
vergleich herausragenden beitrag zum
klimaschutz
hier wird deutlich dass deutschland mit
seinem engagement auf das super
nationalen ebene führungsstark und
zuverlässig ist vor der bundestagswahl
haben wir freien demokraten gesagt nie
gab es mehr zu tun und das hilft kaum
einen politischen bereich so sehr wie
für die entwicklungszusammenarbeit
deswegen haben wir auch in zeiten in
denen nicht nur russland
desinformationen als waffe einsetzt die
mittel für den zugang zu informationen
die medienförderung und zwei millionen
euro erhöht
insbesondere in folge siegreiche klicks
ist die situation in dem von
nahrungsmittelknappheit betroffenen
ländern überaus schwierig wird
beobachten dass allen voran china stark
daran arbeitet sein einfluss in afrika
entwicklungsprojekte auszudehnen
gleichzeitig führt uns heutzutage ein
besuch an der tankstelle auf drastische
weise vor augen wie abhängig deutschland
wie abhängig europa von einigen wenigen
importeuren fossile brennstoffe ist
beide probleme lassen sich auch mit
einer klugen ganzheitlich gedachten
entwicklungszusammenarbeit angehen
schauen wir ein paar jahre die zukunft
war eine brennende sonne heute das leben
schwierig macht kann künftig erneuerbare
energie erzeugt werden so können
praktisch alle unsere partnerländer und
entwicklungszusammenarbeit an globalen
nachhaltigen wertschöpfungskette
teilhaben das kann auch einen
erheblichen beitrag dazu leisten
demokratisch religiös geprägten
energiemarkt dezentral und
marktorientiert neu aufzustellen und
diese zukunftsvorstellungen sollen sich
zunehmend jetzt auch in unseren
entwicklungs haushalten finden und herr
kollege körper ich höre das immer sehr
gerne was sie zu diesem thema sagen aber
muss immer wieder feststellen in ihren
haushalten stand das auch noch nicht
drin aber wir werden jetzt mit diesen
haushalten die nächsten haushalten damit
anfangen und da freue ich mich über ihre
kooperation
vielen dank herr kollege landsmann
und kollege thomas rachel cdu csu
fraktion
sehr geehrter herr präsident lieber
kollegen kollegen die cdu csu fraktion
nimmt ihre kontrollfunktion als größte
oppositionsfraktion sehr ernst sie ist
kritisch aber konstruktiv
zusammen mit der zivilgesellschaft haben
wir christdemokraten die ursprünglich
geplanten massiven kürzungen des
haushalts des bundesministeriums für
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit und
entwicklung kritisiert gleichzeitig aber
konstruktive änderungsanträge hin
zuständigen fachausschuss gestellt als
opposition begrüßen wir ausdrücklich
dass die bundesregierung nun doch
zusätzliche mittel für das bmz vorsieht
hier hat der druck von opposition und
zivilgesellschaft ganz offensichtlich
gewirkt
ebenso positiv hervorheben möchte ich
die erweiterung der bmz partnerländer
und bolivien
lateinamerika hat größere aufmerksamkeit
verdient denn leider verschärfen sich
die sozialen die wirtschaftlichen und
politischen krisen auf diesem kontinent
hier ist ein paradigmenwechsel dringend
geboten dennoch möchte ich gerne drei
bereich herausgreifen die uns in der
entwicklungspolitik der bundesregierung
sorge bereiten in diesem jahr feiern wir
zurecht 60 jahre partnerschaft in der
entwicklungszusammenarbeit mit den
beiden großen kirchen das hilfswerk der
evangelischen kirche brot für die welt
und das der katholischen kirche misereor
leisten einen unverzichtbaren beitrag in
der entwicklungszusammenarbeit
gerade durch die starke verankerung der
kirchen in den zivilgesellschaften
sowohl in deutschland wie auch in
unseren partnerländern erzielen die
kirchlichen hilfswerke eine ganz
beachtliche reichweite und akzeptanz für
die hilfsprojekte gerade in den ländern
in denen die staatliche zusammenarbeit
an ihre grenzen stößt sind die kirchen
weiterhin aktiv doch statt diese
vertrauensvolle partnerschaft zwischen
staat und kirchen auszubauen kürzt die
bundesregierung trotz aufstockung im
ergänzungs haus hat unterm strich die
barmittel für die entwicklungsvorhaben
der kirchen dies wird der wichtigen
arbeit der kirchlichen hilfswerke nicht
gerecht und ist ein falsches signal der
bundesregierung
kommen wir zum themenfeld der bildung
das bmz in der bundesregierung unter
angela merkel das ziel formuliert 25
prozent der entwicklungspolitischen
ausgaben in bildung und berufliche
bildung zu investieren
ich glaube das ist auch dringend
notwendig wir erleben gerade ausgelöst
durch die korona pandemie eine
historisch beispiellose bildungskrise
weltweit
schulschließungen haben alle lern
gewinnen der letzten 20 jahre zunichte
gemacht wegen der korona pandemie werden
zusätzliche 10 millionen mädchen den
zugang zu bildung dauerhaft verlieren
das ist eine echte katastrophe
denn bildung leistet einen ganz
wichtigen beitrag um armut zu reduzieren
und chancengleichheit zu ermöglichen wo
bleibt das klare ziel von
bundesministerin schulze 25 prozent der
entwicklungspolitischen gesamtausgaben
in bildung zu investieren frage ich hier
ganz deutlich
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
wir christdemokraten begrüßen die mittel
erhöhung im bereich der welternährung
aber die politik der bundesregierung
bleibt hier vollkommen widersprüchlich
putin nutzt mit seinem angriff auf die
ukraine hunger als waffe während andere
europäische staaten ihre brachflächen
zum beispiel für brotweizen freigeben
verweigert dies die deutsche
bundesregierung durch diese
fehlentscheidung der bundesregierung
können hier in deutschland rund 800.000
tonnen weizen im jahr nicht geerntet
werden damit könnten und drei millionen
hungernde menschen ernährt werden die
bundesregierung muss diese falsche
entscheidung korrigieren
wir fordern deshalb die bundesregierung
auf erstens bekennen sie sich zum ziel
25 prozent der entwicklungspolitischen
ausgaben in bildung zu investieren
zweitens bauen sie die wichtige
zusammenarbeit mit den kirchlichen
hilfswerken weiter aus und kürze sie
nicht und drittens lassen sie die
deutschen landwirte auch die
brachflächen für den weizenanbau nutzen
denn wir wollen den hungernden menschen
helfen herzlichen dank
natürlich war das für die
unionsfraktionen und jetzt hat noch mal
eine abgeordnete der sozialdemokraten
hier das wort matthias sammer wird das
seien sie sitzt im ausschuss für
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit und
entwicklung
die beratung zum haushalt des
bundesministeriums für wirtschaftliche
zusammenarbeit und entwicklung für
dieses jahr haben es mal wieder gezeigt
das parlament bestimmt den haushalt
aufgrund der vielfältigen krisen den wir
rund um den globus begegnen müssen hätte
es nun wirklich welt fremd gewirkt wenn
der haushalt des bmz wie im ersten
entwurf vorgesehen um 1 6 milliarden
euro gekürzt worden wäre daher möchte
ich mich auch nochmal bei allen die sich
in den verhandlungen zum haushalt für
ein gut ausgestattetes bmz eingesetzt
haben
wir sehen dass die korona könnte mir
auch in den ländern des globalen südens
noch immer nicht vorbei ist und wir
wissen doch alle dass die
wirtschaftlichen und die sozialen folgen
der pandemie in den partnerländern viel
schlimmer sind als die pandemie selbst
die armut steigt rasant die zahl der
hungernden menschen nimmt zu etliche
erfolge der zusammenarbeit der letzten
jahre sind durch die folgen der pandemie
weggewischt
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir sind
ja nicht was heute für einen tag ist
heute ist der internationale kindertag
ein tag der in meiner heimatstadt
leipzig eine hohe bedeutung hat ein tag
an dem die ganze stadt kinder ins
zentrum der aufmerksamkeit nimmt ich
finde wir sollten das alles alle viel
öfter tun die globale situation aufgrund
der korona pandemie sieht vielerorts so
aus kinder leiden hunger gehen nicht
mehr zur schule und arbeiten stattdessen
im informellen sektor wir dürfen aber
nicht zulassen dass es zu einer ganzen
verlorenen generation kommt deshalb
freue ich mich sehr dass wir in der
entwicklungszusammenarbeit einen fokus
auf bildungsförderung leben aus dem
ergänzungs haushalt konnten wir etwa
education can't wait zehn millionen euro
zusätzlich geben damit sind wir bei
diesem titel bei insgesamt 60 millionen
euro angekommen wir sagen
entwicklungspolitik muss kinder schützen
und stärken
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen die
länder des globalen südens erleiden
schwerwiegende folgen durch den
angriffskrieg russlands auf die ukraine
das hat nicht nur unmittelbare
auswirkungen vor ort sondern bringt
weitreichende folgen für die ganze welt
mit sich besonders im bereich der
nahrungsmittelproduktion und dem
transport wir reden hier nicht mehr von
einer ernährungskrise sondern von einer
echten hungersnot in der ganzen region
steigen die brotpreise rasant im libanon
haben sie sich vervierfacht in ägypten
verdoppelt der brotpreis ist ein
politischer preis gerade angesichts der
hohen staatsverschuldung in afrika
sitzen einige länder deshalb auf einem
pulverfass und wir wissen alle nicht wie
lange gelockte noch ist
ich bin svenja schulze sehr dankbar dass
sie im zuge des deutschen g7 vorsitz ist
ein neues bündnis für globale
ernährungssicherheit ins leben gerufen
hat diese aufgabe die ganz klar beim bmz
und ist dort auch genau richtig
aufgehoben und dort brauchen wir auch
weiterhin die nötigen finanziellen
mittel
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wie
gesagt die aufgabe der
entwicklungszusammenarbeit die aufgaben
der entwicklungszusammenarbeit sind
nicht kleiner sondern größer geworden
laut nhc er sind weltweit erstmals mehr
als 100 millionen menschen auf der
flucht diese enorme zahl an vielen
menschen heißt für uns auch wir müssen
für die menschen vor ort echte
perspektiven schaffen denn über die
hälfte der 100 millionen fliehenden
menschen sind binnenvertriebene um den
fluchtursachen zu begegnen müssen wir
präventiv handeln erfahrung vor ort für
die entwicklung auszugeben um
wirtschaftliche und gesellschaftliche
perspektiven zu schaffen
ist ein bruchteil dessen was es kostet
menschen auf der flucht zu versorgen
denn eine weitere zahl für mich in dem
zusammenhang wirklich krass
durchschnittlich sind fliegende menschen
20 jahre lang auf der flucht 20 jahre
ihres lebens
nichts ist der stabilisierende als
hungernde menschen das sollten wir uns
immer vor augen führen natürlich können
wir die bundeslehrer nato oder
un-truppen in krisenregion schicken aber
es geht auch einfacher und auch
nachhaltiger wir brauchen eine ehrliche
wirksam für alle gewinnbringende
zusammenarbeit mit den partnerländern
dabei sprechen wir von einer
zusammenarbeit auf augenhöhe
ich denke wir müssen bald ein neues
kapitel der entwicklungszusammenarbeit
arbeit aufschlagen und eine neue
souveränität für die partnerländer
anstreben der antifa realität gewinnt
kann auf der weltbühne selbstbewusst
handeln und eine gleichberechtigte
zusammenarbeit einfordern und auch
erreichen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir haben
im haushalt ihr geld in die hand
genommen und dazu beigetragen dass der
wiederaufbau der ukraine auch vom bmz
unterstützt werden kann es ist eine
kernaufgabe dieses ministeriums
nachhaltige strukturen und damit
stabilität aufzubauen kein haus kann das
besser als das bmz mit seiner langen
erfahrung und seinen kompetenten
mitarbeiter in an dieser stelle meinen
ganz herzlichen dank an sie alle ich bin
übrigens auch ganz begeistert dass
svenja schulze im bmz eine feministische
entwicklungspolitik zum schwerpunkt
macht und das spiegelt sich auch im
haushalt wieder frauen und mädchen
machen die hälfte der bevölkerung aus
diese hälfte bei politischen
entscheidungen einzubinden und ihr eine
stimme zu geben sollte eine
selbstverständlichkeit sein wenn frauen
die gleiche entscheidungsmacht haben die
männer gibt es einen festeren
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt vielfach
sind es frauen die lokale expertinnen
sind oder fachwissen aus ihren berufen
mitbringen und doch bleiben sie bei
wesentlichen entscheidungen oft außen
vor und werden eben nicht mit einbezogen
um das zu ändern müssen wir bei allen
entwicklungspolitischen vorhaben eine
sender perspektive integrieren
und auf der fotos auf frauenrechte ist
nämlich frauenrechte sind das recht
jeder frau auf allgemeine menschenrechte
die freiheit und unabhängigkeit von
frauen ist der gradmesser einer freien
gesellschaft für alle das werden wir
auch im ausschuss für wirtschaftliche
zusammenarbeit und entwicklung immer im
blick behalten
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
entwicklungszusammenarbeit ist
friedensarbeit was wird uns denn in
diesen tagen bewusster als die bedeutung
von frieden freiheit und sicherheit
entwicklungszusammenarbeit schafft
stabilität auf beiden seiten unsere
gezielte unterstützung der
zivilgesellschaft in den partnerländern
sorgt für die notwendige verankerung von
nachhaltigen veränderungen ich möchte
daher denjenigen die sich schon jetzt
mit denen mit der erarbeitung des
haushalts für 23 befassen mitgeben dass
wir auch in zukunft eine gut
ausgestattete entwicklungszusammenarbeit
brauchen die dem vernetzten
sicherheitsgedanken und unseren
koalitionsvorhaben der eins zu eins
regelungen gerecht wird wer nach dem
haushalt ist vor dem haushalt
vielen dank sagt matthias dahmer hierfür
die spd tatsächlich der haushalt 2023
muss ja in diesem jahr beraten
werden
jetzt hören wir
kathrin henneberger für die grünen und
sie sehen wenn du so ein vorschaubild
wir erwarten auch noch eine
pressekonferenz mit bundeskanzler scholz
und seinem kroatischen amtskollegen das
wollen wir ihnen natürlich zeigen
heute
so
sein wie jetzt wenn ihr wieder ernsthaft
sein wie ehrlich
internationale klimapolitik von
industriestaaten in den letzten
jahrzehnten
die wagen besonders geprägt von schönen
worten aber nicht durch effektive taten
noch immer steigen die emissionen noch
immer sind wir auf einem weg in eine
welt vier bis sechs grad heißer also
genug der schönen worte demission müssen
sinken und die finanzen für klima und
biodiversitätsschutz die müssen steigen
und nach harten ringen in den letzten
monaten lässt sich nun sagen dank grüner
verhandlungen haben wir es in diesem
jahr geschafft dass sie die kürzten
mittel für internationale klima finanzen
wieder erhöht wurden und das ist ein
großer erfolg und da danke ich ganz
herzlich den verhandelnden
wichtig
wichtig war es hierbei auch darauf zu
achten dass titel erhöht wurden die
indigenen gemeinden und die am stärksten
betroffenen regionen zugute kommen sowie
für weitere projekte und für klima
risikoversicherung bereit stehen gelder
für internationale klimafinanzierung
und wir sind verteilt in den
unterschiedlichen ministerien im bmw k
und im auswärtigen und deswegen haben
wir darauf geachtet dass auch dort die
finanzen erhöht worden sind und auch das
wurde erreicht noch das ist ein großer
erfolg
aber natürlich im angesicht der
grausamen realität der klimakrise wissen
wir das kann nur ein anfang sein
damit deutschland seinen fairen anteil
ein held ein internationales thema
finanzen brauchen wir erst ein erhöhung
auf 6 milliarden und dann eine erhöhung
auf acht bis zehn milliarden jährlich
dafür braucht es eine klare zusage von
seitens auch des bundesministeriums für
finanzen das im kommenden haushalt für
2023 die mitte für das bmz nicht weiter
gekürzt werden sondern wieder deutlich
aufwachsen
hinzu kommen in diesem jahr natürlich
auch finanzen viel los und damit für
verlust und schäden durch die klimakrise
hier haben wir eine besondere globale
verantwortung vor der wir uns mit blick
auf die nächste un-klimakonferenz in
ägypten auch nicht drücken dürfen hier
werden wir verantwortung für
klimagerechtigkeit übernehmen
die auswirkung einer ungebremsten
klimakrise können wir eigentlich gar
nicht beziffern und deshalb brauchen wir
eine echte klima finanzpolitik von
anfang an dafür müssen auch endlich
subventionen für fossile der
vergangenheit angehören und dafür werden
wir arbeiten vielen dank
schöner reden jene berger war das ja der
bundestag hat sozusagen fast bergfest
bei den haushaltsberatungen der zweite
tag hier der geht so ganz langsam dem
ende zu einige redner haben wir noch zu
dem letzten einzelplan heute zwei tage
übrigens liegen noch vor uns das schon
mal als vorausschauen damen und herren
entwicklungszusammenarbeit was bringt
denn das eigentlich es bringt viel wenn
wir es richtig machen und es bringt viel
für die menschen im globalen süden und
die gesamte menschheit es bringt aber
auch für uns selbst die entwicklung
zusammen heute ist eine sehr sehr große
aufgabe und deshalb wird es vielen
menschen und bürger in unserem land
schwer daran zu glauben oder auch
erfolge zu sehen aber es lohnt sich
wirklich und die erfolge der
entwicklungszusammenarbeit können sich
sehen lassen
der haushalt 20 22 hat im ersten entwurf
nur 10,8 milliarden gehabt jetzt sind es
über 13 milliarden das ist eine
wohltuende erhöhung um unsere
internationalen versprechen einzulösen
gegenüber den organisationen wie den
vereinten nationen oder zb der
bildungsinitiative global partnership
for education das ist ganz ganz wichtig
weil verlässlichkeit in der politik ist
ein ganz ganz wichtiges und hohes gut
für akzeptanz und ansehen unserer
bundesrepublik
wir haben auch mehr gelder
zusammengestellt in dem haushalt jetzt
für frauen und familien planung für
gesundheit für alles dies sind die
mittel noch einmal erhöht worden und die
fdp hat da durchaus auch ihren anteil
gehabt
noch mehr freut mich natürlich dass wir
auch mehr geld haben für wald und klima
schutz für biodiversität auch das dient
uns selbst wenn wir dann diese
genetischen ressourcen erhalten und auch
unser klima sich nicht weiter
verschlechtert wenn wir dort die wälder
erhalten da heißt es gut so ampel weiter
so ampeln
und die entwicklungszusammenarbeit ist
wichtiger denn je das haben viele noch
nicht so ganz verstanden wir haben eine
zeitenwende und deshalb ist es
hervorragend dass kanzler olaf scholz
nach afrika gefahren ist in die
entwicklungsländer in diesen
krisenzeiten das war ein ganz ganz
großes zeichen und wir müssen uns ja
überlegen wie soll es denn die sollen
den diese länder mit der jetzigen krise
fertig werden ohne unsere hilfe die
hungerkrise die steigenden
lebensmittelpreise
das können diese armen länder nicht
alleine arbeiten und deshalb ist es an
uns jetzt zu helfen bei uns gab es auch
hungersnöte nach dem zweiten weltkrieg
und uns wurde auch geholfen wem sind die
care pakete nicht bekannt wem sind die
rosinenbomber über berlin nicht bekannt
und jetzt ist dass uns dies auch
zurückzugeben
an diejenigen ländern die hungern werden
und das haben wir in diesem haushalt
auch abgebildet und deshalb ist dieser
haushalt ein guter und deshalb werden
wir ihn auch unterstützen und wir werden
auch dafür sorgen dass er in zukunft in
diesem haushalt genügend geld haben die
krisen dieser welt zu meistern zumindest
unseren deutschen anteil dazu leisten
können herzlichen dank christoph
hoffmann war das für die fdp und das ist
nicht sehr spekulativ
wenn man annimmt dass dieser einzelplan
die mehrheit der ampel koalition finden
wird hier in der zweiten beratung die
wichtige abstimmung am freitag wenn alle
einzelpläne gelesen sind in zweiter
beratung und abgestimmt dann das ganze
haushaltsgesetz mit allen
haushaltsplänen das werden sie natürlich
auch bei uns verfolgen